hey guys it's Justine and today I am so
excited because we have got four
different drones that we're gonna be
testing out the pneumatic air just came
out so we're gonna test that in
comparison to but the Mavic Pro Platinum
the DJI spark and the phantom 4 pro
advanced and here's our little Mavic air
my precious
I've never even seen that movie so I
don't even get the reference Serena I'm
updating one of the apps before we go
and then we're gonna start flying I got
two phones one for my friends one for
Mara
[Music]
we've got all four of our drones lined
up we're gonna do a quick little test
basically just getting a nice little
camera view here without anything moving
I do have to shoot the spark separately
because it connects to Wi-Fi and all of
these things are interfering with it
so first we'll shoot these three then
the spark hopefully it all sort of look
the same record record
phantom record 4k 34 k 30 I'm gonna do a
quick little walk in front of it
[Music]
[Music]
so that's the magic Pro platinum out
right now and one of the things that was
new about this is it supposedly is 40%
quieter and listening to it now
it is a lot more quiet even the
pneumatic air
[Music]
that's reviewing the footage from all
four of the drones one of the things
that I was most shocked at was the
variance in color between the four I put
everything on auto auto color balance
out of exposure pretty much everything
so that you guys can see exactly what
you would be getting directly out of the
drones one of the things that I thought
though it was kind of shocking is the
best auto color came from the spark I've
even noticed differences between the two
of the same exact drones like my sister
we both have a Matic Pro and even flying
those on seemingly the same settings
sometimes I will be like this looks
different than yours so I felt like
that's something that's pretty common
but what's great is you can pretty much
customize anything so depending upon
what the light is like so you can set
the color balance to match wherever you
are another cool thing that we tried out
in Malibu is Nathan was flying his
phantom 4 and he added a lot on to his
footage so he was doing this in camera
on the drone so basically what I'm going
to show you now is what he shot this is
right from the drone to your eyes I am
doing no color Corrections all habit
[Music]
shutter speed for drones is that you
should actually shoot with a slower
shutter speed so if you're filming at 30
frames a second it's not a bad idea to
film at a 30th of a second so you have
to have enjoyed NC filter when the drone
is moving through space you're taking
pictures as you shoot video so feel
stepping as you watch playback of the
drone with a sharp shutter that's moving
fast it feels like fun so I started the
day with my ND filter this is the DJI
and this is the 8th filter so far there
aren't any available yet for thematic
air but I do use them when I'm flying
with my maverick or my phantom
especially on sunny days because it
makes a huge difference one of the
things that I forgot to mention on the
mavic air review is they have two new
smart capture features they have the
asteroid and boomerang so basically the
drone will do a set flight pattern and
we'll save that right to your phone so
you're able to share that out
immediately let's say my favorite is
probably the asteroid so basically the
drone follows the flight pattern
directly up so does a really cool
spherical shot of everything around you
[Music]
although boomerang it just takes off and
creates a boomerang pattern so it goes
up outs and then back to recommence
[Music]
so far I'm loving the Medicare it's
amazing but the only problem is the
battery life it does only last 21
minutes which is still a fair amount of
flight time but I'm so used to having
extra batteries and for this I only had
one so I've been struggling and shooting
this video for the past like week and a
half because every time I go to film I
only have like 21 minutes until I can go
back and charge the battery right now
the Sun is going down my battery's dead
so whatever I shot is whatever I shot
the batteries die very very quickly so I
definitely recommend if you are gonna be
getting this do get the fly more package
it is worth the extra money for the
extra batteries because you're gonna
need them hey Jen that I could have that
uh that time-lapse you're shooting oh
I'll buy you dinner I'll buy you dinner
my goodness guys this time-lapse is
courtesy of it's me Jenna a YouTube
channel go subscribe hey do you let me
see the new drone or fly the new drone
at all not yet I'm sorry this is gonna
cost you dinner this is it's me Jenny
Farnsworth's I press the button
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]